[MUSIC PLAYING]
VADIM SUPITSKIY:
Hello, everyone.
I'm Vadim Supitskiy.
I'm head of
engineering at Forbes.
I'm responsible for our
development, our QA, our Del
Ops and data products, and
I've been with the company
for 11 years.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Hi, my
name is William, Director
of Engineering at Forbes.
I lead the team of application
engineers under Vadim.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: And
today we're going
to take you on the journey of
our cloud migration, our road
to the Cloud.
We'll talk about our
mistakes, what we've learned,
our challenges, and benefits.
So hope you enjoy the journey.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Yeah.
So, let's start by talking
a little bit about why
we moved to the Cloud.
So there are three
key areas that
drove us to move from previously
being on prem with the data
center into a
cloud-based solution,
particularly in this case with
GCP, velocity, abstraction,
and stability.
For velocity, we
of course wanted
to increase our speed to
market, delivering more features
to users so that they
could read forbes.com
in the most efficient
way, and being
able to target more efficiently.
CI/CD, a major part, of
course, of velocity making sure
that we could automate our
entire flow as we go along.
And then those both tie to
having a very fluid software
development lifecycle.
Abstraction was
also massive for us
in choosing which
cloud to move with.
GCP and a lot of
the managed services
made it very easy for engineers
without ops backgrounds
or traditional
service-side backgrounds
to jump right into building
applications and getting
that to work.
And also, removed our
infrastructure concerns.
Of course, coming
from a data center
and having physical servers,
that was a whole other level
to worry about, as well.
And then stability.
Of course, being able to
leverage managed Kubernetes
initiatives and more led to
scalability, availability,
and disaster recoverability--
recoverility.
Yeah.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah,
speed and automation
is a forefront for us
everywhere, and obviously
in technology too.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit
about the lift what we actually
had to move going from our
previous infrastructure
onto our new Google
cloud-based solution.
So forbes.com, it is a
website, but the site
when you visit it is actually a
bit over 50 different services
for the architecture
that we have in place,
and those span across the front
ends that you see, sometimes
with different services
for different templates
depending on how they're
served and the level of traffic
they have, as well as multiple
content management systems, as
well as ETL pipelines.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: So we're not
micro-service architecture,
but the service architecture.
Some are micro.
Some are not so micro.
But--
WILLIAM ANDERSON:
Most are not so micro.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yes.
And here's our kind of
architecture diagram
prior to our migration.
I couldn't fit all
50 services here,
but this is kind of
abstraction that I'm
going to walk you through.
We have had two CDNs,
Fastly and Akamai.
We had F5 load balancer which
basically load balanced where
to push the user either to
our dynamic templates, which
would go to Varnish,
you can see there.
And Varnish is our
cache and layer, which
we put in front of templates.
At the same time, templates
talk to API to get the data,
so API is in the
heart of our system.
If not, then the
F5 load balancer
would push the user
or the data requests
to Apache, which would serve of
all the static content, static
HTML, if we have that, all
the Java scripts, all the CSS
files through--
would go through that.
We also had a
different branch here
specifically for our DAM,
digital asset management
system, which included
thumbor open source
software, which re-sized
and compressed our images.
That then went to
Acamai, which cached
and again another varnish
layer and our DAM API.
For ETL, we used
ActiveMQ and MuleSoft
which would process all
our messages, all our data,
and then sort it on
prem MySQL and MongoDB.
We also had some things in AWS.
Our AI skills we moved
to AWS as a first step
kind of a long time
ago, and they're
crucial to our CMS,
so we had that there.
And in a nutshell, this is
kind of our architecture
prior to migration.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Yeah and
then looking at this as well,
as Vadim said, this is highly
abbreviated and abstracted.
So there we actually
have templates in API,
as if those are like
insignificant kind of parts.
But there's multiple template
engines, multiple APIs,
that are powering
all this, and that's
where our core of
our application logic
lives within the larger
abstracted architecture.
Yeah.
So moving to the Cloud,
there were challenges.
If any of you have done
it or attempted to,
I'm sure you're aware
of that as well.
So in one set of
those in particular
was organizational challenges.
We were in a very
fortunate situation
at Forbes where we were actually
able to make the decision
and already had C-suite
buy-in to invest
in moving from on
prem into the Cloud,
and we're also trusted
within our own organization
to make decisions such
as let's move to GCP.
And that's the best
solution for us.
But we still needed
to get team buy in,
and when I say
team buy in, I also
mean like fellow engineers,
DevOps professionals,
networking and security
teams, and making sure
that we're actually all
aligned with moving forward
for that vision,
and we all believed
that it was the right set
of tools and technologies
for us to work with.
Another big thing for
us too was also picking
a consulting partner.
We had it migrated, certainly
nothing of this scale,
to the Cloud before,
and expertise in GCP
was something we were still
developing very much so
in-house.
So we wanted someone
who had experience
doing that multiple
times to guide us
along the way and our
decisions as we went along.
And finally, of course,
picking technology partners.
For that, GCP is one
of them as is Google,
but I also mean
solutions such as how
are we going to
handle monitoring,
how are we going
to handle password
secret storage, and
other additional choices
along the way.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah, and
what is managed for us,
what would we have
to build our own.
So a lot of decisions
obviously prior
to moving into the Cloud and
a lot of challenges as we'll
show you more in the slides.
So I want to touch base
on the migration timeline
and how did we
approach each step.
So first step decide
on the Cloud provider,
obviously was critical for us.
We tried and did prototypes
with three of the big players,
obviously Azure,
AWS, and Google.
We did kind of small
applications that we migrated.
We showed them to our
engineers, DevOps,
and based on the feedback
and just the ease
with which they migrated
build applications
and how did they like
working with the platform,
and just overall kind of.
Cost obviously was part of it
in a lot of different components
there.
We had then decided
to go with Google.
And so far, we're happy
with the decision.
Next step was speaking
to the actual partner
that will help us migrate.
And again, same approach.
We did too week
proof of concepts
was each of the partners.
We had three that we
picked, and the one
that we felt comfortable with--
the team felt comfortable
with, the one that provided us
the best kind of plan
forward, the best
timeline for migration,
we picked that one,
and me started to move forward.
Next step for us was
critical and absolutely
if you're planning
to migrate, I think
this is something
you have to do.
It's kind of discovering
again your systems,
going through inventory of
each server that you have,
each network that
you have set up.
How do applications
talk to each other?
Where do you have
load balancing set up?
Where is the caching?
And what is the
security set up like?
What can talk to each other?
What can't?
This was so critical for
us that without this I
don't think we would
have been successful.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: And
not only that too, Forbes
is a 100-year-old
company, as well.
And we've had a web presence
since there was, well,
like a web.
So particularly for companies
with a history of that nature
too, I think you're going
to find a lot of skeletons
in your closet along the way
or systems you didn't even know
were running that are going
to have to be accounted for.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah.
We definitely have
fallen legacy software
somewhere in the closet
along the way, so.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: A literal one.
Yeah.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: And
so doing that step,
it helped us a lot in the
onboarding the partner.
Right now we had new kind
of diagrams of data diagrams
and architecture kind of
plans of how everything works.
So we could actually walk
our partners through it,
and show them how
everything is set up.
So our kind of onboarding of our
partner was made a lot easier
by us doing that
prep work prior.
So next step was
planning the architecture
and figuring out how it's
going to look in the Cloud.
So we have our
architecture on prem,
and then how do we
move it to the Cloud?
And that went through a lot
of different iterations,
to be honest, and until
we were happy with it.
So that was a step that
was also critical for us.
Then the kickoff, which
was very exciting.
We wanted to move forward
as soon as possible.
And we started migrating.
At some point, obviously,
we realized that we
should do things different.
So that took some time
for us to get comfortable.
But we were very happy
to get everything first
to the development
project, and then
move everything to
staging, and then start
moving into production.
Our approach was to move
to production in phases.
And it was a good
approach, and mostly we
were doing it that way.
But, there were a
couple of gotchas.
We realized that our
core applications
had to be moved together.
And the reason for
that is that when
you have your core applications,
some of them in the Cloud
and some in the data
center, we quickly
realized there is latency
in that communication.
So we had to make sure that
our database, our APIs,
and templates that talked to
it had to be moved at once.
And then everything else we
could kind of stagger along
and migrate as we went through.
We also obviously tested it very
well in staging, load tested.
That's very important.
Tried to simulate
production traffic,
it's not easy but do
as much as you can.
Obviously when you
move to production,
there are going to
be some gotchas.
I'll actually share one.
We have a lot of
traffic to our site,
and what happened to us is
that there is a limit set
on KubeDNS to 150
concurrent connections,
and we realized that after
we started migrating.
So hope-- thankfully we
were able to change that,
but that was
definitely something
that we did not expect.
And yeah, moving to staging
and moving to production,
we had to make sure
that we a the plan
and that we had something
really automated
set up where we can
go from dev staging
into production with
a click of a button.
Next, one of the first
architectural decisions
that we had was how do
we set up our projects?
And we had a couple of
schools of thought there.
One was that we have 50
projects, 50 applications.
Why don't we set up
50 different projects?
We quickly realized that
was difficult for us
and from a security
standpoint was not manageable,
because now the same developer
was the same person will have
access to both production,
development, and staging
application, which
obviously is not acceptable.
The second school of
thought was well then
why don't we just
create one big project
and have all the
applications there?
Again makes the
management extremely easy,
but concerns again-- security
concerns again that developer
will have access to everything.
So we could not allow that.
So the way that we
structured our projects
was something in the
middle, three projects,
one for development and
staging, one for production,
and one for our
management tools.
So something like
JIRA, Confluence,
[INAUDIBLE],, we would keep
in our management projects
separately for security
reasons and overall
for easier management.
Yeah so that that's how we
decided to approach our project
architecture.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit
about how we actually broke up
the clusters inside of those,
which that diagram already
began to allude to a little bit.
So in terms of choosing
what really lived
beside other applications
on like a cluster level,
now that we already
had projects defined,
we broke it up into kind of six
main categories, forbes.com,
which was our varnish
caching layer, all
of our templates
applications, and our APIs.
As Vadim said, having those
live alongside of each other
was absolutely
necessary, especially
once we started to realize the
latency that was introduced
between communicating with the
GCP back to our data center
compared to how fast that could
be if everything was just side
by side.
The other one is our
ETL pipelines and tools
related to that.
We named it Mules, but
it's ActiveMQ and MuleSoft
living alongside each other.
We have multiple content
management systems,
some used more than others.
And all of those
ended up living inside
of another one really
providing access
to the right layer for
our editors and writers.
And that's our authentication
and permissions application
in API, logging, which handles
revision control as well
as access to content
monitoring, our AI skills
which augment writing
facilities for writers
as they go through
creating content,
and social bots as well for
posting to Twitter, LinkedIn,
et cetera.
We also had DAM which handled
thumbor for images, Varnish
for caching, in our DAM API.
Also with the upside
down smiley face
is a legacy one,
which I will not
delve into everything
that is in there.
Spoilers are that it
is a much longer list
than the other ones.
And then finally,
admin or management,
which Vadim talked
about as well, where
we store Jenkins Vault,
monitoring tools, JIRA,
Confluence, and any other
kind of utilities that
allow us to deliver work or
work towards delivering work
in the day to day.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Well,
and the reason the legacy
is separate is
that at some point,
we hope it is going to go away.
And then this cluster
just doesn't exist, right?
So we're looking forward
to that day in the future.
WILLIAM ANDERSON:
Yeah, it'll slowly
be migrated out of existence.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: And one thing
that we had to really focus on
and was new to us in
the Cloud was security.
In data center, we.
Were very comfortable
with our security.
We knew exactly
how to handle it.
Everything was
firewalled nicely.
So we had nothing to
worry about at that point,
because we had so much
experience with it.
Starting to move to
the Cloud, we quickly
realized that it's not
going to be that simple.
The reason is, we
move an application,
it should be accessed-- so
should be accessed immediately,
available to the world, right?
So we immediately started
to pare the access down.
We had to make sure that
only applications that
needed to talk to each
other had that access.
So our diagram we did in
the beginning of our audit
helped us a lot.
We realized which applications
had to talk to each other,
and we would carefully only
allow that level of access.
We also obviously had to
audit all the roles and who
has access to that
project, a management
project or production project.
We left that really a
small number of people
to be able to access to
production and management
projects because most of our
deployments and everything
happens through the
code, so in reality,
unless you really
have to, you don't
need to have access to those
projects by themselves.
And I want to give a shout out
to our security and networking
team.
They've done an amazing job.
They learned all of this and all
these new tools really quickly.
We could not have
done it without them.
They just jumped on it.
They loved it, and they set
it up really, really well.
So really happy.
WILLIAM ANDERSON:
The same, and that's
an amazing advantage that we
really had during all this too.
I realize not every
company actually
has internal networking teams
and internal security teams
to provide assistance with that
and to do auditing throughout,
so having them spin
up their skills in GCP
and apply their pre-existing
knowledge really
just put us in a much
more confident place
throughout the whole process.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: And
learning new technologies,
like [INAUDIBLE] which
we obviously didn't than
have was critical for
us, like kind of how easy
it makes kind of our networking
and splitting traffic
and things like that was
really amazing for us.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: So let's talk
a little bit about the refactor
itself, and what changed as
we went from our data center
into GCP.
So what we originally
thought, and this
makes a tremendous
amount of sense to me,
hopefully it does to
all of you as well,
is we're going to
evaluate if Google
has a managed solution, right?
They have something like
called Data Flow, Dataproc,
like whatever.
We're just going to use that.
It'll be fantastic.
We don't need to do anything.
Right?
If they don't have one for
it, though, that's fine too.
We can move it as it is.
We'll just throw it
in a compute instance,
and we'll refactor it later.
The important thing
for us, let's just
get out of the data center.
So after that though, yeah.
It seemed highly logical.
I led with that.
My bad.
Yeah.
So, but, if we were going to
containerize, we had already
containerized something, why
don't we orchestrate it, right?
And once we have
it orchestrated,
well now it makes
sense for us to include
a network mesh like Istio
into the process too?
And now that we have all
three of those layers as well,
and we have 50 services,
what are we going to do?
But we to automate a way
to not only deploy those,
but to move those from dev,
staging prod, do migrations,
do network updatings,
do patching.
And then, of course,
like we can't
write an individual pipeline
for all 50 services.
So we need to abstract it into
something that can actually
run across all of those.
So while originally
were like, oh we're
just going to move
them into the Cloud
and be done with it, very soon
after we got through step one
we found ourselves going
layer and layer of abstraction
higher as we moved
along with migration.
And I think one of the biggest
things that kind of came out
of that was a highly
configurable master Jenkins
build that does a lot of
what I talked about before.
It's highly parameterized,
which actually
means it requires a
bit of training just
to know how to build to it.
You can hit last build too
if you know the service,
but this isn't just
building something out
like a new feature into
production-- non-production
into dev environments,
which is automated
or moving that over to staging.
This is really for like
setting up our infrastructure
and connections
between new services
as we move them between
those different layers
or introduce a completely
new application
into our architecture overall.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: So if you
needed to set up a new cluster,
, set up node pools,
set up networking,
set up new DNS entries,
everything can be done with
a couple of settings and
the click of a button.
So this file actually
so crucial for us
that moving from dev to stage,
from stage to production,
or introducing a new
application or new cluster,
or even upgrading the
cluster, which happens a lot,
was a breeze for us.
Very, very important to
automate, in my opinion.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Yeah.
Which landed us
with our new stack.
So of course, we've already
talked about Kubernetes
quite a bit.
We also have Google Cloud
Storage, Istio, BigQuery, HELM.
We have Cloud
Functions, currently
just for billing alerts, but
that's also very important
so please set those up if
you're moving over, as well
as ActiveMQ, MuleSoft, HashiCorp
Vault for password and secret
storage.
MongoDB Atlas is our database
for all environments,
but where we're now
in Atlas, as well as
Elastifile, which replaces
our pre-existing headend.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: And
here's our new architecture
diagram in the Cloud.
It's very nicely structured and
clear and clean, in my opinion.
So we have one CDB,
Fastly, in front of it.
No F5 Load Balancer anymore.
The cluster is divided
as we discussed before.
Our core cluster has
Varnish templates
and API really
close to each other.
So there is no latency.
We have the DAM digital
asset management cluster,
which has thumbor for
resizing, Varnish for caching,
and DAM API, our
home-grown solution.
We also have our CMS is a single
application living in the cloud
storage.
Those AI skills that we
had in [INAUDIBLE] we
migrated pretty easily to GCP.
So they have kind of
their own place there.
Then ETL cluster
is also separated.
Again, our ActiveMQs and
MuleSoft, MongoDB and Atlas,
huge help.
Everything can be done on the
fly there, upgrades, indexes,
whatever you need.
So they don't have to worry
about that, so hosted MongoDB
solution.
WILLIAM ANDERSON:
And if you recall,
we were MongoDB before
the migration as well,
but we moved over to
Atlas versus hosting
that ourselves as we were
moving into the Cloud.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah, and
they offer all three providers,
cloud providers.
Obviously we're using Google.
And one thing that we had to
do, for speed we had to be
peer our applications,
Google Cloud and project
to the actual Atlas
project and Atlas Mongos.
So that was very critical for
us because we did see latency
at first, and then after
we did that and the speed
was improved tremendously.
The Apache server that we
had in front of our NFS also
in Kubernetes now, and NFS.
We did a lot of
proof of concepts
and we moved it
to Elastifile kind
of a hosted solution for that.
So yeah, obstructed
a little bit,
but that's in a nutshell,
our new architecture.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: One of
the most powerful things
from this as well is looking
back to our old architecture.
It was a lot of bespoke
solutions, right?
It was like how things had
evolved over time and patched,
and part of moving
over to the Cloud,
and that Jenkins build
we talked about before,
was really taking a moment to
see how we could reconfigure
things and abstract them at
another level, which also makes
for, to be frank, a much
prettier architecture diagram
to present to conferences too.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah, and
Kubernetes everywhere, pretty
much, and Istio for networking.
So the learnings.
What did we learn
from our migration?
One thing, we quickly realized
we have to monitor our costs.
Set up alerts there.
Make sure that you
really estimate
well of what things are
going to cost you, and make
sure you have really
rigorous alert set up
so you get notified
if something happens.
We learned really
quickly, in the beginning,
that we accidentally turned on
debug the logging on our Istio
to go to Stackdriver.
And that, of course
spiked, all right.
We luckily managed to
catch it pretty quickly.
If it didn't, I don't know how
much it would have cost us.
But after that, we set
up alerts really nicely,
and now anything happens,
we get the notification
in Slack and by email that's
something that's going out.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: And
watching those numbers tick up
in semi-real time for the
alerts was quite an experience
as well until we
turned that off.
Yeah,
VADIM SUPITSKIY: It's exciting.
It's different from being in
a data center where everything
is kind of static.
Another struggle and challenge
was taking a lot of new tech
at once.
So I guess then we had to learn
a lot of new technologies,
and we didn't want to leave
a lot of technical debt,
so kind of managing that of
taking on a lot of new stuff
like Istio, Hound that we
had no experience before
and also doing things
right was definitely
something we had to manage.
Team skills growth
vs. a timeline.
Our timeline was
pretty aggressive.
And again, kind of making
sure that the team was
comfortable with new tech, was
comfortable with supporting
cloud, and our infrastructure
in the Cloud vs.
also pushing forward quickly.
another challenge that we had.
And doing a lot
of different POCs.
So one thing that
we learned, and I
think is a great
thing to do is fail
quickly when you do
proof of concept,
and don't get attached.
If something doesn't
work, just move on
and do another proof of concept.
Find the right solution for you.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: A
layer of abstraction
added to that too
was we actually
introduced HELM early
on in our process,
but not at the very beginning.
And it came onto
our radar shortly
after we started and already
gotten some work done.
And the same kind of applies
to the inverse of proof
of concepts if you've already
started down one road,
and then you discover
something you're like,
actually this is just going
to abstract it on a completely
different level.
So we don't have
to worry about it.
Looking at the gains of making
that switch versus doubling
down on the road that
you've already taken
can actually save a tremendous
amount of time and effort
in the long run too.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah, and
the last point is balance
and moving quickly manually
and building automation
was really critical for us.
So obviously, the urge
is to move quickly.
And what we started
to do, we started
to just move things over.
It was Kubernetes.
But a lot of the
things were set up
manually like clusters so that
manual upgrades were manual,
a lot of builds of a Jenkins,
but kind of setting up
security, set up networking.
DNS was done manually.
And we would realize every time
it's like, when we do something
why don't we automate it?
So we would take a step forward,
take a couple of steps back,
and we would do that a lot
actually, at least a few times
for each.
But I think it's worth it.
I think if one
thing that they had
to change, I would try
to build that foundation
and build automation
from the get go.
It's hard to know that in the
beginning, before you actually
commit to because every time
you do something, you're like,
oh OK.
We're doing it manually, why
don't we go back automated?
And at the end,
where we came to is
we can do have all of that
with some configuration
and the click of a button.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: And you might
feel like you're losing time
by taking those backstops,
but especially when
we get in the crunch towards
the end of our timeline,
and it just became choosing a
couple options from dropdown
menus in Jenkins versus
having to do like actual work
to move things along,
it paid dividends.
VADIM SUPITSKIY:
Definitely wouldn't help
you learn that pretty quickly.
And now the benefits, right?
Obviously speed to market.
What it helps us
with was our kind
of process of
deployment, process
of approvals with our
stakeholders and product
owners.
Now we can easily, when
we have a feature, create
a box in which we can
send out all stakeholders
or anybody in the company
to take a look, approve it,
and then we can push
it to production.
Obviously it
reduces manual work.
Now our ops and dev
upstream doesn't
need to do manual patches.
They don't have to go to the
data center, and I don't know--
WILLIAM ANDERSON:
Restart servers.
VADIM SUPITSKIY:
--restart servers.
Not-- none of that is needed
to be handled by us now.
That's all handled by Google,
which we are very happy about.
CI/CD pipelines,
obviously much easier.
Again, generated those
boxes and environments
on the fly for each
application, for each feature,
so they can be reviewed by
stakeholders or QA, critical.
Canary deployment,
so basically pushing
some percentage of the
traffic to the new release.
And then, if it goes
well, push it to 100%.
If not, just scale down.
Destroy the box.
That is really big
for us for our kind
of stability and scalability.
And A/B testing.
A/B testing is something that
is crucial to our company.
We base most of our
major decisions,
or pretty much all our
decisions on, KPIs.
So what we need to
do we need to AB
test every main feature that we
release, and being in the Cloud
makes it much easier.
We can spin up new environment,
point some traffic to it,
then collect the data,
and see how it performs.
And then scalability, all right?
If we need to process a lot
of data, for example, at once,
we can just scale up.
And that's it.
Before that, what we
had to do is basically
over provision or servers and
have huge machines in a data
center that basically were
ideal 90% of the time,
and only were needed
maybe like, I don't know,
a couple of days a year.
So it was a waste,
basically just
to prepare for some
huge traffic spikes.
Now it's all scalable
and automated and Yeah.
We just-- basically
what we used to do
is have huge boxes sitting
there for no reason.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: On the
note of scalability too,
part of that for us in
our particular industry
is also unpredictability, right?
At Forbes, we really share the
stories of people's success,
and some of those people
are very successful.
So when they tweet about an
article or something that's
going on Forbes, that can
generate a pretty tremendous
spike in traffic going to
particular pages or services.
Another thing is we started
to move faster and faster
through all of this
as well was also being
able to scale Jenkins, right?
And getting that
into K-8s, and really
what it was is once
we started to have
a proper pipeline with
boxes built on every pull
request for product
owner approval,
we hit bottlenecks very
quickly when we were still
in the data center.
But moving that
over and having that
be abstracted a layer away,
just removed all those worries.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: Yeah,
but definitely one thing,
make sure that all those boxes
they're not laying around,
and that you actually
destroy them.
So I guess that set
up some automation
that bugs get basically
killed every time
you don't need it anymore.
The way for assets
works is basically
when a developer
creates a pull request,
the dev box gets created,
and when it's merged
it basically gets destroyed.
So, that way we manage it
and don't just create a--
WILLIAM ANDERSON: An
infinite number of--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah.
So, soon to be
integrated or what
we're really looking
towards for the future,
now that we're already in
GCP and cut over looking
to expand that even more.
So like I said, we're
using Cloud Functions.
But right now we're using
them for billing alerts.
There's definitely
more potential there.
There's definitely some
things to be solved along
the way, in terms
of code management,
deployments, and how we actually
handle that with our team
and at scale, but
increasingly so more and more.
Cloud AutoML, machine learning
and AI is major to Forbes
as it is to a tremendous
amount of companies right now.
For us it particularly ties
into editorial assistance
and how we work
with our writers,
though it definitely bleeds
into a number of other parts
of our organization as well.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: It's the skills
that we showed you basically,
and a lot of them are based
on using some of these Google
technologies that are
amazing, and we're really
happy to have those
APIs available to us
so we don't have to actually
write our own NLP or sentiment
analysis and things like that.
So using that a
lot, but as new ones
get kind of created
all the time,
we would like to expand
as much as possible.
WILLIAM ANDERSON:
For sure, and adding
that layer of abstraction helps
our team move with increased
velocity as well.
So Cloud Dataflow
actually is similar
vein for our ETL
pipelines and looking
to see how that might
be able to abstract
some of the more manual
work that we do right now.
Manual being manual coding,
not humans doing work.
Cloud Pub/Sub to a similar
but abstracted effect.
And I think the real
next step for us is now
that we have this whole
architecture migrated over
to Google Cloud is setting
it up with Terraform
so that not only can we set
up and build new applications,
new instances, and migrate
those between dev state
and production.
But we can set up an entirely
new ecosystem on the fly
as we need to.
VADIM SUPITSKIY: And we
already started on that,
and right now as we kind
of discussed and mentioned,
we can create an
application cluster
anything in that environment.
But we want to be able to
with one push of a button
to generate everything
right away anywhere.
Right?
So this is going to be a huge
step for us in the future.
And I think that's pretty
much the next step for us.
WILLIAM ANDERSON: Which
is well under way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]